so now you're not a quarterback now yeah
you'll always be a quarterback but
you're not doing it no like on a
day-to-day basis i don't get paid
anymore right you're not getting yeah i
guess maybe that defines it
do you look at and see like man what a
position i was in like is it different
to look
like sometimes i'll look at things in my
life and be like man i didn't kind of
not realize the position i was in but
you know like to to a regular man
looking at a quarterback you're like
dang that's the guy you know that's
odysseus or whatever yeah i mean
that's a great point like looking back
on it now like you get tunnel vision and
like you don't you don't maybe enjoy it
or have as much fun or take advantage of
it as much as
you would would now looking back on it i
mean you're just locked in and you're
just doing your job and you know it
turns sometimes it's a grind sometimes
it's fun
sometimes it's really hard um but
looking back on it now um you know it
i don't say i don't want to say that i
wish i would have done things
differently but it it it wasn't it was
an awesome awesome experience
it was an awesome experience it was an
awesome experience yeah
yeah it's probably and it shapes a lot
of like who i am and you know the people
i associate with and and how i respond
to things and so i mean it's a
you know from the time i was fourth
grade till you know 35 it kind of shaped
me
yeah i just can't i was trying to think
about something in my life that had been
that much of like a [ __ ] like a thing
that i
was like a vehicle in my life
and i don't know if
i've had that so it just must seem a lot
that you know you're in like a new
career it's like you're trying to find
are you do you want to find a new career
do you feel like you need to or are you
just
kind of like um
i don't know like what do you think like
do you feel like a pressure to or do you
just yeah i mean
because i mean like not many people when
they're 35 or whatever age people are
playing football like
have to go out there and in the real
world and like figure out figure out the
rest of your life right
so
a career career i don't know if that's
right word i think like for me it's more
like purpose like what what is going to
drive me what gives me purpose in my
life going forward
um and there was pressure when i when i
got out to like to figure that out
and i was never one of those guys that
had other businesses or stuff going on
when i played it was literally i just i
played football like i had plan a and
there was no backup
and so now when i got out it was just
like all right i'm
i'm clueless what i'm gonna do i have no
idea
i know the football is over um i knew i
didn't want to coach i knew i wanted to
kind of get out of that world
so it was really just trying to figure
out all right what the hell am i going
to wake up and be happy doing gives me a
sense of purpose
i like it i like the people i'm working
with
and that took time you know and i'm
probably still kind of figuring that one
out
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one